What's the matter?
You know what's the matter. I'm unhappy.
You agreed to play the turkey.
I never agreed. Why would I agree to be the turkey?
You know, it's not a big deal. All you do is cluck, cluck, cluck, cluck, and you wave.
First of all, we don't cluck. We gobble, okay?
I stand corrected.
Yeah. And if it's not such a big deal, why don't you be the turkey?
You want me to be the turkey?
Yeah, come on!
Yeah!
I don't think so.
You know "turkeyisms" that I don't know,...
...even the expression on your face is quintessential turkey.
I don't see myself as a turkey, you know, if it was an eagle,...
...I might consider it. An eagle is graceful, it flies and soars.
The only problem was that the eagle wasn't very tasty.
You're gonna be great.
What the hell are you talking about?
I don't know.
Boy, am I stuffed.
You see what I did there?
No.
I was in character.
You see, that's the reason you should be the turkey.
Maybe next year, I'll think about it.
No, no, no! This is fun. Cluck, cluck!
What happened to gobble, gobble?